GIVE YOU THE LATEST UP AHEAD
ON 8 NEWS NOW AT 04:00PM J C.
THANK YOU GERRI SO IT'S NEVER
TOO EARLY TO START PLANNING
FOR OCTOBER FAST AND BREW IS
BRINGING THE MOST AUTHENTIC
CELEBRATION TO ORLEANS
FESTIVAL GROUNDS AND HERE TELL
US ABOUT THIS EXTRAVAGANZA IS
JOHN BADHAM FROM BREW IT'S
GOING TO
BUDDY, GOOD TO SEE JC
SO WHAT MAKES THIS CTHE MOST
AUTHENTIC OCTOBER FEST
CELEBRATION, YOU KNOW, I GREW
UP IN GERMANY, MY DAD WAS IN
THE MILITARY, I WAS AN ARMY
BRAT.
>> WE GREW UP IN A LEATHER AND
OLD TOWN IN THE SOUTHERN PART
OF YOU KNOW IN THE 70'S AND
80'S THERE ARE MORE THAN
300,000 MET CERTAIN US
SERVICEMEN OVER IN GERMANY AND
SO WE KIND OF GOT THAT CULTURE
INGRAINED IN US AND IT JUST IS
SUCH A FUN ENVIRONMENT THAT
REP, I'M BRINGING THAT HERE.
YOU KN
OW A COUPLE YEARS AGO WE
WANT TO DO IT WE KIND OF GOT
SIDELINED WITH
A COVID WE
IMPORTIMED 5IM00 OIMF IMTHES
E TABLES
YET THIS SEASON IS THIS TABLE
THIS IS FROM THIS IS OCTOBER
FEST TABLE THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
WE'VE GOT THESE WE'VE GOT OUR
FULL ONE LATER STEIN YEAH, WE
HAVE BEER OUT THERE I WAS
GOING TO BE INCREDIBLE HERE
WE'VE GOT OVER 12 DIFFERENT
KINDS OF BRANDS BETTER N
OT
JUST BRAIN EACH OF THOSE HAVE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF YEAH,
HERE'S ASSOCIATE WITH
THEM,
BUT LENNON KUGEL WE'RE GOING
LETTING PEOPLE SIGN COLIN GOOD
THAT I HOLD IT OUT THERE WE
CAN DO THIS THE REST OF THE
SEGMENT HERE EASY WAS NO
LIQUID INTO VERY EASY WHEN
THERE'S NO LIKE THAKET ANKED
YOU'RE NOT A LOT OF DRINK IT K
WHILE YOU'RE DOI
NG THIS ALL
THAT HOLDING OUT THE WHOLE
ENTIRE TIME TALKING ABOUT THE
FOOD YOU HAVE YEAH THAHERE'AHS H
INCREDIBLE FOOD THAT'S
AUTHENTIC GERMAN SO YOU KNOW
JUST THESE ARE SOARME OARF THARR
BAKERY ITEMS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE THE EFFECT OF DRUMMOND
BLAKE AND D D D D D D D THE PRI
GO WHAT'S CALLED THE PUBLIC
AND SO THEY SERVICE WITH THE
BROUGHT FOREST IN THE WORST
AND ALL THOSE OTHER THINGS
THAT YOU KNOW THERE'S GREAT
SAUSAGES THAT WE OUT THERE.
WE'RE GOING TO TO WHICH IS
READ READ READ SAUSAGE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE CURRENT FORCED
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE I'M JUST A
DOZEN A DOZEN OR MORE
UNDERSTAND PROPERLY DO WE KNOW
GERMAN WAS MY FIRST LANGUAGE
SO WE LIVED OFF BASE AT IN A
LITTLE VILLAGE OFAG ABAGOUT AG6
PEOPLE AND SO I KINDERGARTEN
FOR THE FIRST 2 YEARS THAT I
COULD GO TO SCHOOL DURING THE
REAL DEAL TO THE EARLY ON
TRYING TO BRING ISRAEL AS WE
CAN YOU KNOW THER
E'S LOTS LOLO
OCTOBER FEST IN THE BUT WE
HAVE NOT HAD ONE IN LAS VEGAS
LIKE THIS AND WITHIN 5 YEARS I
WANT TO MAKE CARS THE BEST IN
THE COUNTRY AND I KNOW YOU
HAVE SOME ENTERTAINMENT LINED
OUT WHAT KIND OF ENTERTAINMENT
T THATT  T T T RIT SEN 50 ACTS
FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY MOST
OF THEM ARE FRANTIC FROM FROM
GERMANY HIGH SO WE'VE A BAND
THAT'S COMING IN CALLED THE
LADY ALL HAMMERST
EIN'S COMING
INTO PART PART OF OUR SKIS SO
WE'VE GOT A TON OF GERMAN BANS
SOME LOCALS AS WELL THAT ARE
GOING TO HELP PEPPER AND WE'VE
GOT A GERMAN VILLAGE THAT WE
KIND  OF  YOU
ARE GOODS THAT ARE
LOSING TICKET PACKAGES
AVAILABLE BY ONE DAY 3 DAY BY
ONE DAY FOR DAY PASSES WE'RE
HERE THUR SDAY THROUGH SO YOU
CAN COME OFF FOR DAYS BECAUSE
THERE'S GOING TO BE LOTS OF
DIFFERENT THINGS ON EACH DAY
WE'VE GOT A BIG LARGE TRUCK
SHOW AND CAR SHOW BENEFITING
SPEEDWAY CHILDREN'S CHARITIES
LOVE IT SO LOTS OF GREAT
THINGS TO COME FOR THE ENTIRE
FAMILY GOT A 70 FOOT FERRIS
WHEEL OVERLOOKING THE STRIP.
SO YOU'VE GOT FOR THE BOOZE
COME FOR THE COME FOR THE BEER
COME FOR THE FOOD, I GOT TO
WRAP IT UP THERE TO BREAK
THINGS THIS IS NOT A REAL
LEADER HOSE AND YOU HAVE TO
COME OCTOBER FEST RIGHT YES
EVERY LATER HOSE AND DOUBLES
THAT DELAY AVOID WRAP WHICH I
TRY WANT TO TRY SOMETHING TO
TRY PRETZEL UP A PRETZEL ALL
THESE THINGS COMING GERMANY
AND WELL BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
LIKE AMERICAN PRETZELS AND IN
TURN A AND SO YOU KNOW YOU CAN
YOU CAN EAT TOUGH PART THE
COUNTRY PART. AUTHENTIC
GERMANS THEY DO IT WITH
MUSTARD LIKE AMERICANS DO WE
DIDN'T HEAR. THANK YOU SO MUCH
LOOKING DOT OVER VAST  7 OVERS
OCTOBER FEST IS COMING TO NEW
ORLEANS FESTIVAL GROUNDS THIS
IS HAPPENING SEPTEMBER THE
29TH THROUGH OCTOBER SE